If you think back to our discussion of FHIR apps integrated into EHRs,
it should be clear that the decision to initiate the apps rest with the EHR user.
This in turn rests on the user recognizing that an app
exists that might be of benefit in a particular patient.
Clinicians are busy, so it is not hard to imagine that this might not happen.
Very much along the lines first explored by Arden,
the CBS Hook's initiative within SMART
provides a means of imbedding clinical logic within
the EHR to invoke decision support which might or might not be a full FHIR App.
Unlike with Arden, this occurs within
a clinician's workflow and because of FHIR there is no curly braces problem.
A hook is functionality provided by software,
for users of that software,
to have their own code called under certain circumstances.
Clinical examples of such circumstances might include,
opening a new patient record,
authoring a new prescription,
viewing pending orders for approval.
Under such circumstances, CDS Hooks can display cards to
provide useful information or offer apps to help make optimal clinical decisions.
There are three kinds of cards.
Information cards convey text.
Alternative suggestion cards provide an action different from the one contemplated.
App link cards suggest the use of an app or reference materials.
Here, I have used
the interactive CDS Hooks demonstration tool on their site to show how a hook,
inserted into the code for recording new prescriptions,
causes the display of a suggestion card.
This example explains the potential savings if
a generic equivalent replaces the brand name drug the provider input.
Visit the CDS Hooks site for more details.